- So I have to ask about
the "Community" movie
that was announced.
- Oh.
- For Peacock.
- Yes.
- This is incredible.
- Yeah.
- What can you tell me?
Can you tell me something?
I wanna know?
- What?
- Tell me something.
- You guys even know
what that is?
- Yes!
- Yes, we do.
- All right, yeah, we're
doing the "Community" movie
and I can make the big
announcement of what it's about.
- Okay.
- I'm kidding.
I'm never gonna tell any of you people.
- Oh my God.
- No, I would...
No, I'm not gonna reveal anything.
- No fun spoiler? No-
- It's a lot like Star Wars.
- [Kelly] (laughs) Oh you.
- One of them. One of the many.
It's like that. I have, no.
Yes, we're doing it. I'm so excited.
And the cast is excited.
Everyone's back and we're
just gonna be great.
And so...
- [Kelly] That's cool.
- I don't, other than. Yeah, I
can't tell you anything else.
- All right.
Thanks for that tease.
- Other than
everyone dies at the end,
just like in "Hamlet."
Like in "Hamlet," everyone's dead.
- [Kelly] Everyone dies.
- Yeah, everyone dies.
- What a tease.